in Hollywood not everything goes as
planned and sometimes movies simply
never get made as a result trilogies and
franchises that once had Bright Futures
can be killed off before their time
these are the movie trilogies that for
whatever reason will never see the light
of day comic book movies really took off
in the early 2000s with countless
studios giving obscure comic book
characters the big screen treatment in
the hopes of mining gold from pulp so
fans hearts left when geek god Guillermo
del Toro took on an adaptation of Mike
Mignola's Dark Horse comic series
Hellboy del Toro quickly proved his
fanboy bona fides when he chose not to
cast an a-list leading man instead he
hired the picture-perfect character
actor Ron Perlman to play everyone's
favorite cigar-chomping monster busting
gun wielding half-demon critics were
into Hellboy 2 giving it an 81% tomato
meter score but it's fifty nine million
dollar domestic and ninety-nine million
dollar worldwide gross spooked
revolution Studios into jumping ship so
Universal picked up the rights in
Greenland Hellboy 2 the Golden Army this
move paid off with the movie garnering
even better reviews and a one hundred
and sixty eight million dollar worldwide
gross alas Hellboy 2 had the bad luck of
opening one week before the Dark Knight
broke box office records and sales
dropped a mind-boggling 70% in the movie
second weekend so while del Toro hoped
to complete the trilogy he knew his
budget of 120 million dollars for a
final movie was a tough sell finally in
2017 del Toro tweeted that Hellboy 3 was
100% not happening
Lionsgate rebooted the series in 2019
with Neil Marshall as director and david
harbor as the big red guy but moviegoers
and fans said hell no to the new Hellboy
which was a critical and box office
disaster so discouraged a boy
putting it lightly spider-man is kind of
popular the world's favorite
wall-crawler broke the opening weekend
record twice on his own and then two
more times with the Avengers the first
spider-man sent the comic book movie
Renaissance into overdrive in 2002 when
it became the first film to earn more
than 100 million dollars in a single
weekend spider-man 2 continued the trend
and while spider-man 3 ended the first
series with a whimper the Sam Raimi
spider-man film still earned more than
2.5 billion dollars worldwide how's the
PI Sony rebooted the series eight years
later for 2012's the amazing spider-man
this time with Andrew Garfield in the
tights and Marc Webb in the director's
chair the box office results were solid
and the reviews were strong so naturally
before a sequel had even been released
Sony went completely off the rails the
studio announced a third and fourth film
as well as spin-offs for the sinister
six and venom effectively launching a
Spidey Cinematic Universe the amazing
spider-man 2 arrived in 2014 but despite
earning decent box office returns the
horrible review suggested Spidey was
headed in the wrong direction
luckily Disney swooped in and brought
the webspinner back to his
record-breaking ways in the MCU while
Sony scored huge with venom and won an
Oscar with into the spider-verse but
while spider-man is today as popular as
ever amazing spider-man 3 has long been
squished Tron was always a tough sell
for a blockbuster franchise the original
film bombed in 1982 earning just 26
million dollars at the box office but it
built enough of a cult following in the
30 years since that Disney felt
confident enough to spend 200 million
dollars on a sequel and release it
during the holiday season but Tron
Legacy underperformed both critically
and commercially earning 172 million
dollars domestically and four hundred
million dollars worldwide those box
office numbers aren't terrible
especially considering the age of the
franchise but with a budget that high
Disney realized its money was better
spent elsewhere notably only two years
prior to Tron legacies released the
company had begun the Marvel Cinematic
Universe before Tron Legacy was even
released the film's screenwriters were
already working on a script
third film but after the sequels
lackluster box office results the
chances of Tron 3 ever making it to
screens were pretty dicey finally Disney
officially announced in 2015 that there
really wouldn't be a Tron 3 still Tron
legacies director Joseph Kosinski is
holding out hope and he believes there
are Tron fans at Disney who want to make
a sequel happen the Alien franchise is a
classic movie series that to be honest
should have stuck with just the two
films Ridley Scott made one of the
greatest horror films of all time with
1979's alien while James Cameron
followed it up with one of the greatest
action movies ever with 1986 as aliens
although alien 3 had been reappraised in
recent years studio interference forced
director David Fincher to disavow the
film which underperformed compared to
its all-time classic predecessors the
less said about Alien Resurrection the
better but you just can't keep a good
xenomorph down in 2012 Ridley Scott
returned to the director's chair after
33 years to direct the much-anticipated
alien prequel prometheus the film
received soso reviews and earned a
middling 402 million dollars worldwide
despite the lukewarm audience response
however Scott had the confidence to
announce his plans for three Prometheus
sequels but while alien covenant made a
tidy profit thanks mostly to its
relatively low budget it suffered a
steep drop in positive reviews in
comparison to its predecessor
although Ridley Scott and his cast are
said to still be on board for a sequel
to be titled alien awakening the third
film was greenlit before Disney 71
billion dollar purchase of Fox Walt
Disney certainly still sees money in the
Alien franchise it's unlikely the studio
is particularly confident in a third
movie given covenants diminishing
returns
if you suggested 20 years ago that a
movie with Ironman Thor and Hawkeye
would make more money than a film with
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman the
world would have called you crazy so how
did it happen well many factors are
involved but the shocking
underperformance of the DC EU has mostly
fallen at the feet of Zack Snyder Snyder
was handed the reins to the DCE you
after mane of Steel performed relatively
well on its release and also because
Christopher Nolan probably wasn't
interested despite fans disappointment
with Man of Steel and bat
versus Superman dawn of Justice each
made money mostly because they featured
the most popular superheroes ever made
unfortunately Snyder's Justice League
wound up lacking and earned a relatively
low amount at the box office considering
the movie's iconic lineup of heroes so
where would Snyder have gone with the
series if things had been different
according to Kevin Smith the to Justice
League sequels would have featured the
Green Lantern Corps and Darkseid while a
quote Snyder cut could be in play for
HBO max you can be pretty certain that
Warner Brothers won't be spending money
on any sequels anytime soon the
Fantastic Four have had a rough time at
the box office starting with the 1994
film that's so bad it wasn't even
released in 2005 the trend continued
when Fantastic Four earned in atrocious
27-percent tomato meter score however
the movies light tone stood out against
the doom and gloom movies released that
summer and an earn decent returns at the
box office
154 million dollars domestically and 333
million dollars worldwide naturally
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
did just as badly with critics but this
time it flopped at the box office
while all five main cast members were
signed to a three-picture deal a 13%
box-office drop with a 25% higher budget
gave Fox executives pause for thought
whatever fans the film had left all
their hopes dashed when a pre Captain
America Chris Evans said a third film
probably wasn't happening but even
though that trilogy was doomed Fox tried
to relaunch the series in 2015 this time
with a darker tone that was totally off
the mark resulting in the worst reviews
and box office performance yet Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige recently
teased the Fantastic Four's MCU debut so
here's hoping the team finally gets the
big screen outing they deserve in 2012
the mouse house released one of the
biggest bombs of all time John Carter
based on Edgar Rice Burroughs 100 year
old book series John Carter is about a
civil war vet who's transported to
Barsoom aka Mars where he gets wrapped
up in the fight between the Tharks and
the red Martians sound like a stretch
while Disney didn't think so the company
spent an astronomical 250 million
dollars on the film
some reports going as high as 300
million dollars making it the most
expensive original movie ever made in
the end John Carter made only 73 million
dollars domestically and 284 million
dollars worldwide week numbers for a
film on a modest budget but absolutely
devastating for one that cost over two
hundred and fifty million dollars in
fact if not for the Avengers
record-breaking run in the summer of
2012 John Carter's failure might have
sunk Disney's live-action film division
for good
since then director Andrew Stanton has
revealed there were plans for a trilogy
with the next two films already having
titles and plots based on Burroughs
books John Carter's total collapse
obviously killed those dreams but Edgar
Rice Burroughs estate regained the
rights in 2014 hoping to bring the
character back to the big screen while
Leonardo DiCaprio followed up his role
in a James Cameron record breaker by
making movies with Steven Spielberg and
Martin Scorsese Sam Worthington followed
up avatar with Clash of the Titans hey
maybe it seemed like a good idea at the
time a remake of Ray Harryhausen's 1981
star classic the 2010 Clash of the
Titans also had a stacked cast featuring
ray Fiennes Liam Neeson and a CGI Kraken
needless to say of reviews were brutal
but the movie made enough money to buy
real estate on Mount Olympus the sequel
wrath of the Titans did just as badly
with critics but much worse with
audiences making measly returns at the
box office
Warner Brothers was already planning a
third Titans film but the sequel steep
40 percent decline
gave the suits pause by 2013 the film's
producer declared Titans three dead on
arrival unless there were fresh ideas
although you'd think that the entire
span of Greek mythology would have
provided at least a few and while
Worthington smore recent career has
subsequently disappointed at least now
he can look forward to doing some more
avatar independent state was one of the
seminal summer movies of the 1990s it
blew up the box office in the summer of
1996 and went on to become the
highest-grossing movie of the year when
a movie makes that much money especially
on a modest budget it usually means
sequels lots of them but a funny thing
happened on the way to outer space
summer after summer big movies came and
went but an Independence Day sequel
never
happened but 2015 was the year of
nostalgia so Fox figured that
Independence Day resurgence would be the
next blockbuster sequel to rule the
summer boy were they wrong there were a
few problems firstly resurgence didn't
feature original star Will Smith who
opted not to return and had his
character killed off second the film
wasn't just bad it was really silly -
wait a minute go consequently
Independence Day resurgence seriously
underwhelmed with an alarming 53% drop
on the originals returns a fallen
figures that's even more startling
considering the 20-year difference in
ticket price inflation clearly
moviegoers were over the series given
producer Dean Devlin is over it - and
how the Disney Foxx merger has shaken up
all of Fox's slate you can safely bet
that there's not going to be an
Independence Day 3 in Earth's future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you